is that little medical miracle for some
having a baby is the most natural thing
in the world but us Mara and her husband
were forced to turn to science in what
was an emotional and grueling journey I
felt like a failure I felt as if I
couldn't achieve something that others
are achieving on a daily basis and so
naturally from struggling to conceive to
the birth of her son through fertility
treatment
the additional battle of cultural stigma
has made this process for us myrrh even
more difficult it wasn't until we
actually started speaking to people that
people's reaction was like well hold on
a minute here you know you went in that
route science you know that's God wanted
it to happen it would happen and that's
when the dose really started asthma is
one of the very few British Pakistani
women to take up fertility treatment
like IVF in the UK she feels it's
because other women like her have and
will face similar problems it's a
cultural mindset no matter how much we
try to adapt it's that cultural element
of it that we need to remove that's what
we need to address new figures handed to
Sky News from the government independent
regulator for fertility shows over the
past five years the number of women from
Abbey AME background undergoing IVF
treatment has increased by over 20
percent the Bangladeshi community has
seen an increase in over 40 percent
there's a 38 percent increase in the
number of Chinese women 24 percent
increase in women from an Indian
heritage and almost 20 percent more
women from a Pakistani background are
also accessing IVF treatment the
authority believes some of the increases
down to more patients declaring their
ethnicity but they want women from these
backgrounds to feel empowered to access
IVF more information and empowering
women with the right knowledge will
demystify IVF and make it just like any
treatment but the stats also showed the
already low number of women from a black
background taking up IVF treatment last
year are even lower than in 2013 Vanessa
took two rounds of IVF and
has a one-year-old son but after her
experience she wants to normalize
conversations around fertility in her
community I feel that as a community
there's always there's always an image
or having to become feel strong or
appear strong and that you're handling
things so having to go to people and say
we're struggling and the image that
almost puts on the man let alone the
woman is is I think a bit overwhelming
for a couple to be open about it's in
these types of communities where
fertility remains a huge taboo and often
the assumption is that the problem is
the fault of the woman and it's them
who are on the receiving end of outdated
and accusatory comments resulting in
serious feelings of shame but it's
talking about the end result that women
from these backgrounds have achieved
which will help others in the future
because we have a beautiful medical lots
more women from Abbie AME background are
fighting the social and cultural stigmas
and undergoing IVF treatment the number
is still incredibly low it's moms like
Vanessa and asthma who are living proof
that turning to science can give them
the family they always wanted into my
machine Sky News